et là maître international bounhar
guyenard mamadou bâ donc bien sûr
fouillis fans est la grande favorite de
ce match
c'est d'ailleurs la favorite du tournoi
en général donc c'est voilà donc ça
serait très intéressant de regarder ça
je pense que je pense qu'elle a des très
grandes chances donc ça c'est le premier
match ça vient ça vient de commencer
donc elle a fait une espèce de française
versement à attaquer ce mondial voilà
c'est ce qu'elle a à faire et qui
tendent donc bon je pense que oui femme
saura comment comment défendre à haïti
noirs ici et en fait ça ça serait le
dernier match le dernier match de la
première phase de jeu donc il y a déjà
eu beaucoup de matches et beaucoup des
résultats vous bien sûr d'assif vu que
il passe alors à la deuxième phase
donc les gagnantes de la première phase
passe à la deuxième elle se rencontrent
en ce moment là et ça c'est le dernier
match
donc après ça ça sera le leur pour les
gagnantes de 100 rencontres et donc ok
donc quel point son cavalier ça c'est
très normal ce qu'elle a fait avec
cavaliers des deux cavaliers fanga va
lire qu'à vih de bombe et emmené son
cahier angers 4 j'imagine tout ça c'est
très typique h5 quoi elle peut vraiment
jouer l'offensive
donc elles ont toutes les deux déjà
beaucoup réfléchi en fait parce que là
ça a commencé à 5 minutes donc elles ont
déjà réfléchi un peu un peu plus de deux
minutes déjà
également au oui donc là la colonne b
qui s'ouvre il ya peut-être d acheter ce
qui arrive qu'avait g4 aussi comme on
l'a dit je suis là assise peut-être fou
g5 mais faut bien défendre ceux qui ont
fait 5 avant de faire ça
wasquehal j'écarte ça me semble plutôt
normal il ya peut-être tour b3 qui peut
arriver pour attaquer se fiancer 3
même en on peut le défendre avec la dame
ont alors avec le fou mais si on défend
avec le fou alors là tout à ce moment là
il peut rentrer peut-être envie de
l'être aussi des cahiers à 5 qui vont
arriver pour occuper la case d3 donc
pour vous faut des deux ça me semble
simplement peu risqué c'est pour ça
qu'elle a fait à vous et vous voulez
bien garder le contrôle de leurs de la
case donc malheureusement la dame là il
sait pas grand chose de la france dans
ces deux à part défendre
donc c'est ça le petit problème en fait
c'est que la dame du coup elle est un
peu ne fait rien et le fossile sort et
ben vous il y aura quand même autour b2
donc tous ces pièces là est son histoire
en défense elles font pas grand-chose de
france et donc mais je pense qu'après
damas cinq ça sera déjà un bel avantage
pour les noirs parce que quand ça
quasiment forcé de faire fou mais deux
est-ce que ce fou se rabattaient sur
eux-mêmes fou prend des trois ans votre
four b2 faut prendre des trois dimpre en
est toujours fermée deux banques voilà
ça a pas l'air top dont damas cinq ça a
l'air d'être vraiment bien je pense
qu'elle sera oublié de défendre avec
foot d2 parce que comme on a dit surtout
b2 il y aura foule prend des trois donc
faut des deux c'est plutôt c'est plutôt
normal et en plus du que la tour est là
qu il défend la case c'est pas en
dessous si elle peut faire food et de
son ensemble trop de problèmes il ya
plus qu elle peut menacer ses 4 donc
ouais donc ça plus tentés
donc au foyer fatah réfléchit beaucoup
c'est c'est un peu risqué de réfléchir
autant surtout vu la cadence que ça ait
rempli sa patte à plus de réfléchir à
l'aja une mine d'or à la pendule donc
elle l'a bien fait mais il y aura
sûrement foulée de oui oui c'est ce
qu'elle a fait sur ces 4 il y aura des
4es la position se ferment même si le
pion à 3 va tomber c'est pas un truc mon
souci parce que sur la prise après il y
aura toujours un karima qui attaquera le
kg aura donc voilà dans le bessin que
c'est bien vu il y aura sûrement fouet
faim pour défendre dames et deux oui ça
serait ça sentait pas trop ça c'est ça
c'est bien parce que surtout reprendre
ronde 1.46 aura la troupe qui sera en
l'air en a deux donc ça c'est bien du
c'est très embêtant d'ailleurs je pense
que goulard or un des sacrés problèmes
bientôt
donc là il peut tenter des trucs comme
ces cartes peut être mais je pense qu'il
y aura juste prix et après dam des trois
qui varient mais pour échanger les dames
et mais surtout pour avoir une position
on peut préférer abus oral pour 1 3 qui
sera en l'air en plus on attaquera la
lecavalier après l'échangeur colonna
dise est quadrillée cela s'annonce très
ouvert ok donc peut-être quelques juste
prendre en fait et après prend l'option
me sens si elle prend avec le cavalier
ou 28 cents par l'air du col objets
prendre avec le fou et la dame peut
rentrer à l'air pas mal ça le cavalier
aussi peuvent être en très basse côte
des cars pas possible expliqué le fouet
en l'air mais simplement essayé
d'échanger le tarn devrait bien
puisqu'on veut sans après la rochelle
c'est trop et c4 le chlorate roja tombé
au saut
c'est ce qu'elle a fait ok c'est
franchement cavale il a pourchassé faire
après peut-être prendre et après faire
un cercueil à 5
ok donc attaque le fou sur ses cartes
avec le fruit peut revenir comme ça
je peux bien phu dix minutes mais je
sais pas si on attend de le faire ah oui
en plus ça peut être dangereux parce que
si on a six mois mais le foulard il ya
peut-être la dame qui mélange de 5
donc ouais c'est pas top top 4 c'est ce
qu'elle a fait ok m et du poumon
ok faut aux deux c'est peut-être
possible pour rester chez elle c'est la
dame
donc
réfléchis pas réfléchi à ces montants je
porte quand cooke en fout de ça serait
bien pour essayer de chasser la dame et
c'est de gagner le pion je vois pas trop
ce qui a dérangé là dessus en fait
surtout que le fouillis faisait rien et
fin c'était vraiment leur de la ramener
dans le jeu
peut-être mythe le caféine qui la
préfèrent tour bien et normal qu aura
trois équipes attendent donc le hockey
c'est moi mais c'était très c'est très
moche pour les plantes y aurait cahier
prend les cinq ou six mois salir superbe
je me coûtant peyre juste le plus gros
lot
réponse b accueille 3 5 la salers
mortels salaire de juste gagner ce qu'à
manille en phase précoce du clonage
elle tente de s'échapper mais ça marche
parce que je pense que d'abord donner
bientôt tam si un homme ok donc faire
c'est aussi bienvenu way for ça
j'imagine des kf3 en ne formulant la
tour
je pense que ce maïs était temps
d'abonnés en effet
ok donc on va prendre mais elles ont une
petite pause peut-être que godard et et
vénère et la famille de recommencer très
parce que d'habitude les parties
s'enchaînent c'est un peu bizarre
d'ailleurs que ça survienne pas là si
elle se trouve ainsi un trouve qu il a
la classe et son ordi l'a balancé par la
fenêtre
ok enfin ça a repris donc la bouillie
fin d'année beau ayela réfléchi effet
celle ouvrant son premier coup c'est
bizarre ça c'est très bizarre
apparemment elle a peut-être un petit
soucis de connexion
on irait c'est bizarre ce qui se passera
donc voyons voir peut-être qu fouillis
fana des problèmes elle n'arrive pas à
avancer la partie c'est pour ça que
c'est pour ça que là ils ont dû arrêter
j'ai donc ça reprend nous moquer de 4
si une française donc ok
donc ça c'est la ligne la wii la wii la
wii ware donc la grande ligne 7 pouces
et le centre moi j'aime bien qu'ils
avaient lieu deux cem à petit les
crédits mais oui le 5 5 1 dans la grande
ligne
ok donc la dame g car c'est peut-être
possible oui c'est de choquer le pion g7
a plus tenté
maintenant bat donc vous pourrez aller
pour la ligne un peu plus tranquille
alors donc bombe et si ça dépend la
pluie incessante
j'imagine qu'elle va et va peut-être
tête prendre effet ce défaire c4 ok vous
faire ces quatre direct donc solide et
sûr présent ça peut-être te prendre
quand même et du coup il s'est d'abord
le cul en fait blanc c5 les deux pions
sont doublés d'ailleurs et peut-être
faire des fous et 3 donc c'est pour ça
qu'elle a pas appris
donc bien sûr et peut échanger des fous
mais on n'a pas trop le choix en fait on
est quasiment obligé prendre parce que
si on ne fait pas il y aurait quand même
eu faux français 80 obligé de prendre en
affaires
[Musique]
donc ça a l'air un peu bizarre de vous
donner le roi comme ça mais ça va ça va
totalement le pue le centre des nobles à
l'air encore nation mais ses pions
peuvent être aussi un peu faible on peut
les attaquer et surtout ils n'ont pas
vraiment de menace donc ça a l'air
d'aller en fait c'est une position assez
à double tranchant agirait
ok donc là elle réfléchit fait chez
banco
ay si si c'est peut-être possible
elle effectue un peu trop d'ailleurs
lala déjà au 15e coup à boire déjà déjà
j'ai tendance à mais bon il faut que les
deux groupes étaient déjà perdu beaucoup
ton en dessous perdu beaucoup de temps
on pouvait fauqué de la caisse active on
peut donc là bien sûr ça ça attaque ça
attaque la dame n'a jamais pensé à
proposer l'échangé ouais donc elle a
pris
et ces six pour faire pour leur a
peut-être poussé des 4
ok donc là il ya peut-être fou c'est
simple en fait parce que secours sekkat
j'ai l'impression que ça donne oukase
mais oui il ya le patron show bat donc
c'est bien lui de la part de vos iphone
ça va le faire flouer 3 sa force c'est
quatre essais 4 on n'a vraiment pas
envie de le faire à qena voilà la celica
sais c'est vraiment terrible il qu'avec
qui peut rentrer que foule qui peut
rentrer ans et cinq des six aussi bas
salaires vraiment vraiment difficile à
jouer ça donc je pense que oui tu as
déjà gros avantage pour fouiller fans
juste le vieux qui ont des seins qui
peut être mais ça aurait collé la tour
noire peut essayer de venir rechercher
des pions en b3 ça peut se tenter alors
peut-être tourbillon pour essayer sur
retour premier set de rap retourner vite
après il c'est de faire ça le même la
tour suivra peu importe où on ira à
paris
en dix-sept en fait c'est du coup
surtout frein tout reprendre tourbes et
8 ya tour 17 parce que tout retour des 8
on peut juste rond et après faire faire
faux bond à 7
c'est pour ça qu'elle l'a pas fait donc
elle essayait de chasser les fins de
capturer ce pion est peut-être qu'on
peut essayer tour 17
quand même de donner plus on vote parce
que c'est pas très grave et après on
reprend il y en prend en d5 salaires bas
si mal surtout que là on se retrouve
avec rinaldo fout plein de cavaliers et
le pion sega sera toujours faibles qui
ont à cette aussi donc le hir istres 2
d'y avoir des soucis pour pour les pions
noirs ça se tente au peut-être de
pousser mais on s'est vraiment trop
risqué parce qu'après la prise pour
tours 17
le caribou on aimerait bien faire faut
des cas comme ça marche pas trop donc
serré c'est un peu trop tous risques et
ça même s'ils sont un poids ça c'est
joli mais oui elle a fait la fête pour c
est du coup donc c'est un peu bizarre ça
en chemin un peu bizarre j'imagine que
sur la prise elle de venir chercher le
client à mai mais du coup je pense que
c'est un peu mieux de faire tourner
cette haie d'essai de chercher le pion
des mêmes
la fée tours 7 du coup a apprise
diaspora peut prendre direct on va 700
euros pompe
on verra ce qu'elle fera de vous la
france est intéressant de mort
ok donc mais réfléchit bien toutes les
deux ont déjà passé pas mal de temps
monsieur donc elle a bien pris donc à
d'accord d'abord il changer une paire de
cavaliers après le régime mesure va
apprendre en recettes
donc c'est pas très facile de faire des
progrès ici surtout que qui ont à 3
risque d'avoir des problèmes il faudra
faire des fausses armes pour essayer de
le défendre et après éventuellement
pousser ou vous venir avec le roi le
venir venir en débattre avec eux aussi
il ya peut-être éventuellement des
possibilités comme ça sur ces diagonales
mai mais bon ça s'il ya si la défense
des noirs et et précise ça devrait
passer de cause
en plus y'a peut-être même caressé 6,6
pour forcer un fou ou faux c'est simple
et ouais mais bon dieu cay est très
calme obligé de repartir
c'est vrai que ça serve pas grand chose
donc et si sa défense a est le mieux
pour le coup si la diagonale donc à 4
hockey logique à quai c'est celle où on
en avait parlé mais yuko après ça elle
est obligée de revenir non c'est pas
très malin on potes
c'était mon idée aussi mais c'était pas
très malin parce que du coup c'est le
cas du coup j'ai après il y aura un sens
qu'à essayer sa femme anne gailly il est
assez mal placé là on puisse y aura des
détours ses cinq peut-être qu'ils vont
gagner pionts même à un tour c'est 5
vous pouvez yakari b3 donc 3.75 et après
il y aura une retour pour la 4
donc là peut-être mieux passer leur
lampe est vu que la longue le cas bailly
est mal placée et un montant en fait de
venir
ok donc à la fédé change donc elles
pensent pouvoir pousser ses pions en
tout cas peut-être forcé le cas veille
de défendre ce pion comme ça ne pourra
passer le roi ça c'est ce qu'elle espère
on trouva entre le entre le fait
d'espérer les fêtes de marché fut que ça
marche c'est mon univers une chose ou
même on verra bien là il ya là je pense
que ça fait marcher ça fait peut-être
marcher c'est la même pour moi après
qu'elle essaie de pousser les pions
ça a l'air d'aller ça a l'air d'aller
donc 3 3
si le roi bien sanctuary y aurait eu les
cartes peut être ou alors fou au fossé
7,6 origami encore mieux ok
d'accord on ne veut pas et veut pas
laisser la poser
ouais donc là celle-là salaire ça l'a
vraiment bien salaire salaire plutôt
bien peut-être que l'on peut venir à
attaquer c'est lui aussi
ouais on peut même je suis posé sur le
si leur aura bien on peut prendre des
cinq après c'est qu'un bâton mais aussi
y'a toujours est-il qu'il sera en l'air
ou s'ils bloquent le cas est obligé de
défendre
ouais sursis au roi mais ici c'est déjà
fini son camp des 5es bas sinon
j'aimerais le pion l'attend donc là on a
juste à faire un six cavaliers b6 pour
défendre
depuis on l'a tous les gays de plomb et
voilà je pense qu'on pourra peut-être
pas et tu es 3 et 5 ou alors même même
ses débuts d'abord et après bressan qui
s'est mis à rechercher les lions
ça a l'air très dangereux ça 3,5 suroît
bessette on est injuste prendre nos
pions cette eau je pense que c'est fini
en fait après ça
ok donc elle peut pousser les pions mais
ça risque pas d'être une très grosse
menace
je pense qu'on peut juste venir chercher
les deux ans et après le bloquer avec le
faut mais là on a peur la peur du coup
elle essaie de faire faux b4g malines et
après passé sombre oui ça va ça va jean
des 80 juste apprendre sur donc sur sur
web qui sera sûrement roi baisse indique
non ok sans pudeur faire avec les morts
elle a changé en peu de plans mais c'est
assez départ pour changer de plantes
mais n'aurait dû complexe mike semblant
d'allant dans mon âge il y aura juste la
promotion bientôt c'est impossible à
stopper d'ailleurs on pouvait même
poussé le plan directeur
alors que jusqu'au procès sèchement
ouais voilà donc elle a réussi là une
dame et ça devrait terminer bientôt donc
el ghany donc oui fan 2 0 c'était assez
prévisible surtout vu la différence de
niveau il y avait une sacrée différence
surtout qu'au fouillis fans est
clairement la meilleure joueuse mondiale
active en ce moment alors que alors que
boulard elle est ramenée à seulement
elle est un grand maître
c'est quand même une grosse différence
au niveau donc là c'est une française de
change
bon assez symétrique très symétriques
d'heure
voilà donc voilà on fait un jeu croire
pour empêcher info j'ai quatre séismes
ces trois ça serait pas faire acheter
cela faut regarder la symétrie
elle n'a pas fait ok donc en tout
revanche sont établis des deux mêmes en
faut quand même essayer de deux dents de
changer un peu la symétrie
sinon ça sera ça sera ça serait très
ennuyeux fouet trois c'est possible
j'essaie 4 ce jeu vous j'ai senti ça
peut santé
donc acheter c'est un peu embêtant parce
que la sueur fois je trouve acheter
assura peut-être même g5 en fait il y
aura pas de cinquième de sacrifice et du
coup il ya fou j'ai trois compères en
commun pattes mais bon c'est vrai que le
rock des noirs c'est un peu une fois on
peut détruire les plants seront très
avancé donc ouais c'est pour ça qu'elle
a fait ça donc donc dany le fou la paire
de fou ça va bien donc c'est vraiment un
sacré bonus pour les north sait qu'elle
peut tenter des fous et 5 mai mansat
votre sens celui que cette semence et
son hongre en faut mais bon juste pour
échanger la part de food est grave
peut-être là je pense que ça peut se
compter un petit mais bon là c'est mon
devoir de jouer donc j'imagine ça
ressemble à ça peut se tenter
noob et 4 c'est peut-être à 4 ce jeu de
ce truc à elle assez faut être simple ok
non surprise d'un enfant
ouais ça a l'air très égale ça quand
même je dirais qu un petit avantage pour
les normes csa la peine d'être très très
égale meilleur meilleur ennemi caillou 5
qui peuvent arriver outre la culture des
ans aura faut prendre f5 d'un pont il y
aura peut-être quelques 5.4 ok c'est
intéressant ça donc que je te créer des
petites menaces et tout juste juste en
nous embêter un peu et aussi libéré
cette case pour certains mots pas où
c'est presque symétrique d'ailleurs
cette poule y sont c'est marrant la
seule différence c'est que c'est en me
refais le fouet le cavalier cette hausse
c'est trop drôle en fait elle l'a copié
si elle se trouve elle l'a fait juste
pour la forme et soco vous pousse à
s'échanger alors qu'elle et 5 ça
peut-être ceux tentés donc voilà bah
ouais donc à bon c'est pas totalement
symétrique mais ça l'est presque
c'est drôle ça ok donc comment trouver
un plan là des deux côtés c'est pas si
simple
il ya peut-être eu du vent ni 4 à 4 mais
bon c est se gagnent c'est un risque
vaut mieux ne pas faire de grosses
concessions comme ça et vaut mieux faire
des trucs du genre ça peut-être essai de
manioc riz des pièces mais si on bouge
huckabee pkk trempette
du coup c'est vraiment parce que je
pense que le mieux c'est à lui de
tourner et de rien faire
mons a réfléchi
donc moi je ferais bien un ticket à
veilleux 5e je tenterais bien ça ça
dépend du choix des noirs ici mais je
tenterai bien au cabillaud 5
ça a l'air d'être la menace en fait non
peut-être quelques voulu qu'elle fasse
trop madame des six pour m'empêcher tour
à 6 heures il y aura l échange
c'est tout ça c'est pas mon tournoi ça
donc elle a bien essayé d'empêcher km5
hockey
donc comment elle peut plus faire sont
curieusement on s'en prend du temps pour
attaquer c'est d'être au canada mais
c'est risqué
je pense que vaut mieux mieux 9 n'aime
pas faire des bons trucs comme ça
c'est fou ces cartes ça sera pas à toi
parce que ça se crée en planque de lait
sert apparemment d'ailleurs c4 je pense
ouais c'est des vies c'est super
difficile de trouver un truc donc elle a
essayé de bref je pense qu'elle va
vouloir bouger son travail et peut-être
après et après les sept fois claire et
simple ou alors elle avoue le juste
topoline et les plans des noirs mais du
coup il ya peut-être gsi sympathie à la
dame sera obligé de revenir
ouais c'est ce qu'elle a fait
ok donc là ça a l'air d'être pas mal
donc
la comcom dira j'ai ici sera g7 s'est
pas c'est pas si facile mais c'est pas
facile pour les noirs de faire des
progrès non plus mais progressivement
enfin six français maman fin ok donc
elle a vraiment compris café d
absolument rien faire mais roy et enfin
c'est quand même un choix bizarre alors
ferrer pu faire des trucs de voir que
tour d en être mais royer france a fait
un petit mot rim à elle a proposé 9
boulevard à proposer nul fouillis fans
ne veut pas là nul donc la bombe sur
dame prend yurika veilleux cadre donc il
vaut mieux prendre avec le cavalier là
et après il ya petit qu'il ya peut-être
fait le piment hk qui arrivent là hk je
le ferai bien ouais donc oui je ne
l'avais pas encore une très belle pole
ici la colonne h qui s'ouvre aux
salaires mental ça donc là peut-être
prendre avec la dame et c'est d'échanger
les dames pour éviter l' attaque
ok donc l'a pris comme ça mais du coup
il ya peut-être pas tour qui va
peut-être revenir comme ça ou alors je
sors des tours aux six essais de doubler
essaie de doubler comme ça surtout que
là le câble donc disons surtout rossi
surtout reprendre d'un prend il ya même
pas tous rangs parce que le caféine a pu
en effroi il défendu donc voilà ça a
l'air vraiment bien
donc elle a tout le temps du monde de
doubler sa satour l'ère saddam
tétreault 6 mètres la tour en achètent
pour taper sur le pion à f3 ça peut se
faire ou alors qu'ils avaient eu quatre
ça peut santé moi je serai bien torah
chute ouais je suis d'accord avec elle
du coup je suis quatre week-ends frange
les quatre sets c'est tentant mais ça
marche pas parce que roeder une dame
j'ai trois reprises d'un point indom jeu
3-3 donc malheureusement ça marchera
donc là faut défendre je pense
donc je sais pas ce qu'il va se passer
ça 4 du coup hop on l'a pris c'est pas
bien j'imagine que ça se faire un plan
bath et donc vous mais faire d autres
trucs mais mais mais alors quoi alors
qu'adam et eve 4 mai la finale ça sera
pas top
après les gens ont peut-être une plume
affaire d'hommes wen en fait non
d'ailleurs je pense que ça nous ce que
la finale sera très également je pense
sur damas quatre cas répond d'un ponton
dames 2 du coup aux quais n'ont hélas
pas mais ça est allé cacher son cavalier
ok alors david katz attaque samana se
paye ses cinq peut-être mais du coup il
y aura peut-être dame du tout là et
après la dame peut-être bouger la tour
peuvent être montrés aussi mais à waimes
et non du coup parce que le cari sera en
l'air beaucoup d'âmes là ça sert pas à
grand chose qui aurait juste tour à tour
m2 dans le box d'un me 3 bien bien super
bien vu ces attaques le pis moi je
trouve ça menacé change d'âme
ok donc les quasiment vous êtes prendre
chez moi pour les gitans que ça parce
qu'il y avait plus on restera là y'avait
pas trop d'autrefois
donc là le pion est toujours en leurs
mais cela y accueille autres cadres qui
arrive tout va le tour j'ai trois
peut-être ouais ça l'air terrible donc
oui fans qui va avoir 3 0 ça fait
beaucoup
cette le pion alors ok donc un peu en
quarts 2 qu'avec mes trois à me faire
tours 2
ouais donc m6 est malin parce que des
forces ont pu en l air et se permet de
faire de bouger l'europe
sur deux y avait ça alors là c'est fini
ça c'est archi faux
leroy qui vient en plus
ouais
voilà donc il me reste juste à choper
les pions mais c'est tout de même
prendre là
donc elle se bat toujours avec une arme
à la bourre mais fait mais bon là je
vois pas trop cette trousse qu'elle peut
faire il y avait juste le plan qui va
arriver à dame d2d ans après les options
qui vont aux petits ont poussé donc je
pense que ces temps d'abandonner
donc elle a perdu autant ok et alors
donc là encore vous pour partie le pense
ou alors c'était l'heure de la pause
déjà c'est que c'est l'heure de la pause
en général après la première la première
moitié de deux des cinq plus un
en journalier un petite pause mais ont
normalement sur les huîtres en un peu
plus tard que maintenant
mais bon ça se trouve ça vraiment lors
de la pose déjà
bon bah dans ce cas là si c'est la pause
alors moi aussi je vais faire ma petite
pause et je reviens tout de suite
donc je coupe juste à kamal à la caméra
mais vous verrez tout est toujours le
chic
il sera toujours là donc vous verrez
quand ça reprendra donc à tout de suite
ok donc ça a repris et je suis de retour
donc ça c'était une française dont
française homme mineur et cette fois
elle a joué aussi avec eux 5 c'est la
ccim enel que ce qu'on avait eue avant
je crois sauf que cette fois la paf
ouais elle a fait voilà enfin les dames
ou bien ces quatre qu'elle a poussé bon
c'est un peu différent car c'est très
différent
donc bon la dame et hop
pas super bien placé mais on n'est pas
si mal non plus mais on aimerait bien
que fait des menaces sur le roi ici mais
ça va être très difficile je vois pas
comment faire peut-être que le jeu sera
plus tôt ou plutôt focalisés à la loi
fait ont repassé la dame en même temps
ça salaire normal parce que surprise y
aura quelles vih 4 or pour reprendre une
option h5
ok nom qu'elle réfléchit elle a pas trop
envie de prendre apparemment la famille
de secondes kayak h4 suite dedans prend
1,5
clairement quand me de dessins donc bon
tu y es fais pas ça c'est pas si simple
série n 5
franchement ça aiderait pas grand chose
mais déclassé à laquelle pétantes
escroqué donc c'est ce qu'elle a fait
donc là bon on voit pas trop ça menaçait
de prendre et l'empêcher l'écaillage 4
mais du coup il y aura cavailles h de là
pour prendre comme ça tu as payé azéri
en plus le truc cool de secours c'est
que elle peut aller angers car faire de
m6 si elle savait vraiment pas
ok donc allégé c'est donc revient à
mesure mon mais du coup il ya peut-être
fenêtre ça on prend vite la callas ou
non mais si on fait ça la femme c'est
qu'il ya sûrement des cas vh1 qui m'ont
empêché ou alors juste ce pas une très
grosse menace pas d'être bon qu'à
attendre dix ans semble ok mais bon elle
n'a pas fait donc à ce qu'il a fait
aussi l'homme il l'a fait ok donc ok
donc sur h 5 euros sur mon kayak 6 g5
aussi le par ailleurs et qu'alexis
caillage 5 mai aura calé pour acheter ce
que j'imagine donc haut-salat à bien sa
dette comme ça pour les bourses
donc là une poussée défiance à pourrait
être assez nombreux si elle arrive à le
faire peut qu'elle peut tenter à 5 jeux
med h peintres ou demain
moi j'ai deux peut-être qu'on fait
retour à chaud ça vous est possible
ouais je tenterais bien se trouvera dans
l'ancien hawk est intéressant donc sûr
j'ai ça mais je vois pas trop son billet
en fait qu'est ce qu'elle veut faire
vite d'un patient c'est assez bizarre si
elle veut pousser g4 mais ça pas trop
tente parce que ça te détruit le dow va
donc jouer gens l'idée fait pourtant que
blizzard ok mais bon c'est bouillie
fanahy doit savoir qu elles doivent
avoir une idée wheadon ok donc et
voulait juste à forcer la peau si j'ai
cinq et a fait venir au quai après
revenir et après peut-être venir en
acheter un
c'était donc ça arrive peut-être faire
fou j'ai cassé à ce moment là faire tout
marchand d'accord donc et voulait juste
forcé ses vins attentes et les noirs de
pousser g5
alors c'est bizarre ça c'est très
bizarre de prendre d'échangés sont bons
cavaliers contre compte de mauvais fou
super bizarre très bizarre ok donc elle
a fait ça à la maison d'amour h5 mais la
llose ariste d'abord des petits soucis
pour elle
sa position n'est pas top il ya des
matins qui peut revenir 8 ont tiré
celle du coup ça t'amène un peu bloqué
au site auquel adam à partir ayora
lioran la menace c'est de mettre les
tours là aussi pour protéger
quel g7 si la dame bouge tes quand on
sera de h5 qu'une fois que le pion sera
protégé ok elle a fait le coup comme je
pensais même qu'ils aient changé d'âme
je sais par un pack ouais bah écoute ça
peut aller en fait pour les noirs les
changes de domme et après il peut mettre
une tour la clé mais c'est pousser les
pions
oui parce qu'en fait aller avec des
plans souvent à temps il est blanc
posters tour à shanghai ici et il n'y a
pas la pousser à acheter ma soif ou
pranger 5 donc là elle a le temps en
fait de faire toujours à chanteloup g4
on dirait meilleur des cas légers c'est
le cas à la fin qui défendra cette case
et qui permettra la poussée des jeux set
ça a l'air de bien bien non je viens de
faire
tu es torah 5
en avant
c'est un panel savons même pas où
acheter un clin pas amis et veut mettre
son fou là ok pas mal aussi 500 foule ne
vous a pas grand chose donc autant lui
assure une meilleure direction d'al sadd
vrai
ah ça oui ça peut être marrant surprise
y aura tous ces cinq on pourra rentrer
en baisse
la mairie veut bien faire ça
donc là lors l'ordi dit que fou prend la
salle est tout petit fou points 5e rang
et tout h 1
ces gagnants ce genre énorme avantage
pour les cons j'avoue que je ne crois
pas trop cette évaluation à six parce
qu'après tout racheter à kia f4 et donc
ça affaiblit ok donc
donc en fait tout prendre sa lettre c
c'est gagnant pour les parties
bien sûr les normes ne peuvent pas
reprendre avec le cahier parce que leur
faut qu'on utilise mais bon elle n'a pas
vu donc elle a fait tous âges de huawei
tourache on est pour empêcher ça c'est
d'ailleurs bien pour elle que beaucoup
l'adversaire ici n'est pas fait à chaque
sort était assez assez assez dommage
mais c'est comme ça donc ok donc ça
c'est ce qui arrivé
elle tourne tourne à 6 ha trouve
maintenant elle va le faire ah bah non
elle l'a trouvé à trouver la défense et
en suisse avant là c'est un peu
différent
y avez-vous que la tournée qu on achète
bien qu donc la pousser à 4
josé sablos tenté ou alors faut des six
ok
qu'est ce que le faire un bye bresson il
lui reste six secondes
ouais donc là ses apartés de mamie cette
ferme annuel fixé ce cours elle
abandonne sa nature mais bon je pense
qu'elle veut garder son score par faire
je pense qu'elle va toujours essayer de
gagner
quoi qu'il arrive par hockey senior à ce
moment-là nous répéter lui donc
ok donc là c'est une passe à commencer
par une française mais après ça s'est
retrouvé dans un monde si celle ci est
fermée avec dame de quillan plus
bizarres supervisors pas d'ailleurs
ok donc l'ordi il avait bien des cinq
offrandes et 5 et cahiers des quatre en
avantages du mauvais placement de la
dame mais après du coup la dame est
obligé de défendre l'appuyant et
reprendre avec le pion à 5
le pion à eux en disant voilà c'est ça
c'est ça qu'ils avaient bien mais bon
elle l'a pas fait pendant que ceux là
bon là je pense que il ya une grosse
menace de kehl et des cas du coup et les
casiers de l'empêcher avec ses 3 ou
alors à moi en caisse
on n'a pas trop envie de le faire de
vous mais faire c'est trop je pense à
plus de ça ah ouais c'est plus typique
pouvaient être des 6/7 sommes laissés de
couleurs
ok donc elle a échangé donc bien sûr
vous comptez si ça marchait pas nous
rendre
vous prendrez cécilia il faut prendre
dassin qui n'ont que c'est pour ça que
afrique la dame est
et voilà donc laquelle il ya trois
semaines j'étais là par cas et c'est de
laisser pousser des 4 ou alors peut-être
caillaissé 4
ok c 4 donc qu'est-ce que la prévenue
surprise c'est prendre donc d4
on va se retrouver avec en plus en vue
de nez je sais pas si c'est un bon choix
ici elle peut faire aussi kayembe simple
on va prendre avec le cavaliere est
possible aussi franks à ce que la paix à
fois ci c'est bien vu oulala c'est bien
mieux ça très bien venu d'ailleurs parce
que sinon elle se retrouverait pas mal
si elle prenait avec le cavaly mairie
fois ci ça s'appelle 15 tous sont blancs
et va se retrouver supérieur il
maintenant avec après dépenser 300 ch
pas à ça c'est terrible sur la prise en
plus avec les pensées 3 alalala à je
pense que là et peu à peu près ce que
free s'abandonne gens
bon bien sûr qu'elle prendrait s'il ya
juste faut prendre deux ans après you
for your info première 3 et fo nds
donc ça on n'en parle même pas
donc elle réfléchit la pauvre boule
noire 1 je sens que ce match ne va pas
bien aller pour elles mêmes ont vu son
adversaire assez sympa chance à deux et
de tomber sur son iphone
surtout on encore tout à la première
ronde c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
moche plus elle aurait pu tomber sans
apporter quignard elle même
du coup elle juste pas de chance pour
elle donc monde ne peut pas faire grand
chose si elle fait un truc du genre tour
d un je pense qu'il y aura juste appris
cela elle aura quand même beaucoup de
ponts 22 pions - et aux cdd pièce mende
active telle qu'elle peut même prendre
ici après faire cailler b4 ou alors je
prendrai ici et faire x files
donc attaqué me pousser le cuir l'eau ou
alors on fait pas un pas peut-être
pousser les pions effet retour ce but ça
oman pour garder le plus bas c'est un
message qui se plaint il va être en
belge sait pas si c'est une bonne idée
de le faire ou alors t'as qu'à peut
faire un fouet 6 c'est peut-être
possible fou et qu'il a menés en bateau
si ça marche un bien quand je vais faire
si ça marche
ah ouais voilà l'ordinaire pas tant que
ça il dit que tout vrai fils samuel
aydie que tours fc vite c'est mieux
ouais parce que du coup si on prend il y
aura il y aura taux plein ouais prendre
en b2 ça va trop de sens parce que mucha
faut prendre après son faux départ je
sais c'est pas top comparé à ce qu'on
pouvait avoir enfin développer et 10
leno les pleureuses développer ça peut
ça passe et pop
il vaut mieux hausse et se reprennent
après leur capture hier avec avec une
pièce
ouais donc bien sûr si on compte sur la
grille et ça sera pas top il y aura
foule il y aura tout cas la tour qui
arrive après le fou qui arrive en haïti
est aussi les plus tard donc bon il faut
aussi dire que l'option à c'était un
vrai rythme mais ça a pas l'air d'être
en gros soucis parce que perdre ceux qui
ont assez de ces pingouins sais pas
c'est pas terrible hein c'est pas sympa
ça pas la fin du monde
du coup il y aura ça j'imagine qu'à
valider trois peut-être ces deux aussi
ok donc elle a pris tout mon norman ok
donc c'est bien qu'elle soit ce qu'ils
se soient gâchés ambiante parce que si
l'italien au b2 il y aurait eu carrément
fou avis donc c'est cacher ou bien ouais
on plane on fait ya beaucoup de menaces
très grande menace d'ailleurs s'avança
[Musique]
donc s'il a le tour qui arrive
ok donc là on va se développer sur la
diagonale ça serait assez logique 20
faut vraiment faire quelque chose soit
s'il n'y a pas trop de courrier blanc
ici donc autant activer ces pièces
ok donc à essayer de faire la pression
sur ce cavalier je pense qu'elle a
essayé de faire toujours à 4 au 6 mai
bon seuil est bien défendue pas mais il
est bien défendue donc voilà tour à 4
mai mais bon y'a peut-être même qu'à
laisser 3 et 6 ans surprise en reprise
après ça s'est très bien défendue par à
part les deux pièces
ouais ça c'est bien aussi mais ce
qu'elle a à faire
moi par contre faut vraiment bouger là
il faut bouger la dame ans parce que
sinon il va y avoir un fou prend mes
quatre peut-être d'annoncer cinq ou
alors cavalli ces deux peut-être en tout
cas faut faire un truc faut pas la garde
et la dame ça c'est sûr peut-être dames
cette dame 17 aussi pour pouvoir prendre
avec le fou mais bon ok elle a choisi
d'emmener 5 est donc surtout ses entours
siens puisque me faire aux banques de
prendre le banc avec humour prendre le
pion mais ça me concerne c'est une bonne
idée ça pour prendre le clan
des trouées faim pour défendre sa le
seul moyen d'ailleurs de défendre
pendant qu'elle fasse oui enfin là c'est
étiez-vous des quatre mais il ya eu 5 du
goût le 5 est ce que ça marche comment
alors dit oui dis que ça marche à peu
près mais la preuve c'est qu'il y avait
hier cinq sont encore wade aime pas trop
surtout qu'elle est celle ci n'a pas
trop ce qui se passe donc il a une âme
paul 5 bat il dit que cinq sets gagnants
à kozuka et ses six donc qu'il aime bien
oui c'est tour des huit
il a mis autour des 8 haye pour attaquer
le cavalier et si les kabyles bull via
tours poids des ans celui de kamel de
d'un point en banque
donc ouais tour des mythes salaire le
salaire c'est bien en effet ce en fait à
gagner en plus en dieu à moins que la
dame défendre ce karine silla des siens
après tour dit la dame défend il y
aurait eu cinq à cause du plj ouais elle
l'a fait c'est bien donc est donc
maintenant elle a juste à gagner sion
non pas tout de suite en fait foi qu est
ce qu elle peut le faire
non non ça sa part de marché
[Musique]
oui il ya il ya tout point b casseront
pas de si elle fait ça y est après il ya
d'un des huit celui d'un enfant c'est
cette donc certains marchands sa superbe
revers faut pas qu'elle la fasse à cause
de tour quand beckham qui a vraiment
super dangereux ça donc faut qu'elle
fasse entre une genre alors dit lydie à
c'est un combat pour défendre ce
cavalier et après pour prendre en droit
elle l'a fait ok c'est bien c'est bien
de vérifier comment le comme leur dis
donc ouais donc là on menace de prendre
c'est le meilleur du coup c'est une yole
à ce que s'est défendu sa
ah bah voilà on peut juste prendre je
pense qu'elle fait avec avec la dame à
sa part autant si on allait beaucoup
mieux je suis pas faire un truc pour
défendre mais bon du coup elle elle l'a
pas fait mais là je pense que c'est dieu
sait déjà tout
c'est archi faux donc voilà il ya tous
vraiment repris klose 33 avions c'est
vraiment trop mon père a non goulard a
perdu autant et il reste en pointe
saisit donc après ça ce sera l'heure des
détroits +2 déjà ça sera l'heure des
beats un peu plus rapide
donc les bons encore je veux la même si
j'ai l'impression qu'avec la dame qui va
venir ses cachets ont bien voyons voir
si ça sera le cas
auquel réfléchit elle veut pas vu la
même ok dame g4 intéressant j'aime bien
ce genre de coups active donc je suis
contente et je veux ça mais bon il a pas
l'air de connaître un bon ok ok donc
elle a juste d'un des gardes juste parce
qu'elle voulait bouger droit elle
voulait que le roi rouge est que
l'europe plus peur hockey font ainsi
enfin fois ci c'est un bon coup en fait
parce que du coup ça ça empêche le rock
prenons
ouais htc pour empêcher callas lundi
ok assez intéressant et couture a pris 0
il y aura des français 5 et après le
cuir en a cinq se retrouvera très table
le mental c4 aussi le printemps qui
montera à bas coûts en france
j'aimerais bien faire ces 4 après
ossements pour mettre la pression
d'entrée sur son pion mais d'abord bien
sûr faux où alors déferlante et 2 mai
2002 ya peut-être ces quatre hommes
s'étaient eux ces quatre ouais c'est que
tu leur dis dis que il dit car ici c'est
mieux pour défendre le pion à 5 9 a
failli même passé 4 pas donc ça y est
bien qu'il s'agisse d'un quai ouest ok
du coup il a fait h5 l ap ap santa fe h5
ah oui ça c'est agressif ya quand même
ok alors c'est la garantie plancher qui
fout c'est une fois à troyes et pour
essayer de mettre le faut sur cette
diagonale
parce que le fou fait absolument rien
des donc ça il serait bienvenu percer là
ok donc à préfère attaquer
ah oui le coup là une belle opposition
roi et lui ne suis pas sûr ça sur rapide
on peut quand même peut-être faire lever
le pain seront en effet je pense que
c'est fou aux fumeurs
mais ben on aimerait bien faire
comprendre à 6 mai mais du coup il ya
quelques années qui défend à mais non
mais il ya ça en fait ça va ça il faut
prendre six à bail
certains parmi sa gamme spirit trop
proches d'assad sagan direct à temps aux
appels la famille ça super ok elle a
fait donc tout reprend et il ya un flou
fromages sont classés sont peut-être
avec quasiment obligée de faire tour a
juste pour défendre l'action celle de
suez environnement peu mais ignorent
ayora d'amis ah non il y aura pas demain
parce que la date oury en l'air hogen
entourage suite c'est un bon coup des 20
plus hauts et sur sa balle arrêtée pour
tourner un autre plan on avait déjà
parlé c'était ça
tour à tour il faut pas la face et comme
on l'a dit bien sûr dans le match 3
c'est pas possible à cause de revoir
projet 7 donc voilà donc voilà c'est
quasiment on est obligé de de faire un
point un peu plus tranquille c'est le
fassois gabon elle répond j'ai réfléchi
beaucoup et il reste 10 minutes et demie
et après ça serait la fin du 2 5 pouces
de ce sera l'heure du 3 plus forte des
cinq plus un essai trailer du 3 + 2 donc
voilà mais bon on réfléchit trop faut
vraiment qu'elle joue ça qu'elle vous a
parce que si elle français lucien quoi
il faut juste fou prend 1,6 voilà donc
elle a enfin fait donc qu'à beaucoup
possible mais là je pense que fin ce
plan c'est vrai menu c'est vraiment lui
eut à tour ne veut pas vendre notre
attaque et parce que cavalli est simple
quand on reprend même en courant coup
pour revenir aussi comme ça ça devrait
aller au ciné c'est pas très agressif
mais ça devrait aller
elle a fait ses volumes s'écoulent
elle joue vraiment bien de quoi ces
parties là je suis assez contente de sa
qualité de jeu c'est plutôt cool
elle trouve la plupart des coûts de
l'ordre au caire donc c'est un sacré
changement par rapport à certains des
matchs qu'on est mon avis donc oui donc
l'afua 3 est il menacé
dans ses mots
ça va être très difficile de survivre
ici c'est mon pas si c'est possible
après
y'a plein de trucs qui peuvent arriver
là genre qu'elle y est j'ai six mois et
quel geste je pense que ça je pense que
c'est le souhait weppes et auquel ils
n'ont pas tort mais on attend je lui
faire du bien comme ça
ah bah non mais juste du jeu souvent
votre faux français impeccable 6 à
toulon mais qu'arrive-t-il si ce jeu je
peux pas trop aux joueurs page probable
sinon je tenterais bien ça ok donc c'est
ça qui arrive est donc à fait d'un monde
dames b cet homme tente et sam on a
maintenant mais que pouya ça oui c'est
pas assez
pie x est tout petit avantage pour les
blancs du coup parce qu après ça si
auquel et progressait qui aura voyage
c'est tout alors sur sûre qu'elle prend
à chaud ici à wavrin je suis trop bref
cette touffe au courant mais ça a été la
cas dsi s'est défendue par une carie ça
ne marche pas ouais youku ouais faut pas
qu'il fasse un faux pas avec des micros
étaient plutôt quelle façon il faut
prendre 7 mai après kenya toutefois
well as et je suis
donc là plein des changes mais bon line
tyne est fortement quoi lasser arrive à
sauver ça va être incroyable
alors puisque le cahier qui arrive à
prendre un tour c'est 8 continue jusqu'à
les 2,6 à ce point c'est pas voir le
ménage parce que le race étant de créer
des trucs ici donc là disons qu'elle est
de 6 à 3 faut bien calculer parce que
bon c'est la rive à vous une dame ça
sera assez dangereux qu'on a fait mais
je pense que ça et que ça devrait aller
à la limite a peut-être même de
sacrifier leur tour pour le cavalier à
faire don d'un budget cet essai de matt
est comme ça après avoir ces systèmes
prend 1,7 à 2 sais pas c'est pas clair
c'est pas clair on fait donc ouais faut
pas une question après 6,8 à quelque
bien qu'elle peut faire d'un match 4
j'allais dire d'un match caf a pressé de
rentrer là ouais à trois dames 18
apprécié de 6 de faire des trucs comme
ça
donc là ben ouais à trois dames du
salaire défini donc bien vu bienvenue de
saint pardoux avoir fait damage cas ça
bloque vouloir être le tout les menaces
ça bloque tout
donc là c'est là c'est justement parce
que sur caelestis du coup c'était super
risque est un pote et des 6 à trois
points quand même un jeu vous allez
quand même aux abords avoir des nerfs
d'acier pour jouer ça avec les blancs
donc c'est mieux que je me sois
ouais et la gamme super super 5 ennemis
à 0 et demi est encore là nul c'était
vraiment tard pura chances que le bo n'a
réussi à l'avoir été gagnant du wif and
mail a pas réussi à trouver le meilleur
ou et yoplait l'apa bouton l aller pour
la nuit ac non à la rue déjà si pente
ok ça c'est encore une variante des
changes comme condom mais c'est un peu
différent cette fois protégé ça
peut-être protégé comme ça pour nous à
ce qu'il faut faire ça
elle réfléchit avec la chine ouais ok
donc là je choisi celui-là ça peut-être
peut-il être aussi faire des trucs du
genre kerry à 3 passes et le cahier en
c2 nous mettre en e3 du coup la mifa
nantes et quelque part c'est simple fait
toujours ça aussi ok ça aussi c'est pas
mal
pirogue trois petits roquets justo assez
suis super solide ce genre de position
moi je sens très bien entraînés par le
rock mais c'est mais bon ça va en toi
ok je vous la passe et son cas mais là
c'est une manoeuvre a pas mal c'est pas
mal on pourra peut-être kg 6 ou alors
juste et rock
bon ben adda peut-être caillage 5 mais
du coup il y aura petit rock se passe
quand même un bon alors jusqu'à quand je
suis franc jeu c'est peut-être un
certain dr top
vu que la colonne hsc ouverte et qu'on
peut faire grand roque et après c'est
grossier l'option en cars 2 qui aura
donc peut-être poussé à mais du coup si
on fait grand effet que les noirs ils
m'ont aussi par mon oncle wayne simmonds
qui vont clairement pas fait retirer car
je pense me monferran que c'est pour ça
qu'il a fait cette fois d'ailleurs elle
est maligne les machines et veut
attendre que les noirs font face du rock
mais du coup ça arrivera roll napoli
fort bon que ça c'est sûr mais c'est
pour ça qu'elle a fait le trou
d'attentes cette drôle d'ailleurs elles
attendent de voir ce que ce que laissent
que vous ayez va nous refaire
ouais donc l'aapia trouvé afin petit
recul lent médium c'est vraiment trop
c'est un message rock comme comme prévu
donc on aidé à tourner peut-être
et d'ailleurs ce match ça risque d'être
le dernier match en fait le dernier
match 2 bis non le dernier match 2 2 5
pouces 2 et après ça sera l'heure de 3 +
2 mais voilà ça sera assez ça serait
assez intense ok donc l'ofs faut prendre
les prendre qu'à elle prend il ya
d'hommes des cinq attaques le pion à 1 2
ça a l'air bien ensemble
ok veut clairement échange des fous
c'est un bon choix en fait parce que ce
fou est bien plus actif que le fou blanc
le temps vient de s'écouler donc c'était
c'est bien la dernière partie
alors que faire pour les noirs est donc
être amené une touriste y être emmenées
en fulham et du coup sûr foule ayora fou
c'est dingue ça sert à rien wade donc
plutôt à mon tour l'a poussé en flandre
assez intéressant mais sur sur des
prendre que faire alors mais que faire
sur des points et en plus ça où on peut
le rock
non sans but bizarre ce choix sur la
dame là elle doit bouger
ok ok ok donc en échange d'armes ça
serait ce sera la faveur des noirs ici
ne faut pas le faire ça sera en faveur
des plans pardon donc il faut pas faire
plutôt revenir parce que sur d'armes
français tu aurais eu dame f4 droit ces
deux on ne voyage il aura des petits
problèmes
je pense y aura même je suis lâchée par
m donc ok on sait ce qu'elle a à faire
là est la page et l'aï changé d'âme ok
ça parce qu'elle a fait donc
bon salaire salaire me croyez pas non en
fait ça
tour leurs actes fous là
tours décèdent pas la défendre eric
besson et sautez donc peut-être la
repasser le voit on met le val d'adour
surtout rajon le prince et qui aura bien
à saint-cricq magie et après la tuw eh
ouais est-ce qu'on peut donc ok donc sur
sa à cinq escales prévues
pas si simple
tant qu'elle peut faire et s'ils
essaient de faire ça et poussé le
plomber la torah ok donc là il faut pour
l'annuelle jeu la pression
b 3 suivi de ces quatre peut-être ouais
ce qu'elle a fait
cette trentenaire à tour ici aussi bon
là c'est la sfopho tenir mais je pense
que ça peut ça un peu avec elle m'aurait
peut-être tenir leurs pulsions
f4 donc j'imagine qu'elle veut faire des
trucs du genre ça essaie de poser
bon là il est obligé de faire ça ou g5
ont bien vu sa superbe hervieu donc j'ai
3 bien sûr ça perd le curage pas appris
sa perle faut donc b4 bien vu aussi de
sa part c'était le seul coup des vans
superbes yeux seront donc sur offre
surtout francs il ya tout reprend et
après prison à 5
donc ça a l'air de bien se tenir et sur
la prise en d4 j'imagine qu'il y aura
toujours à 7 et sur trois des six en
fait ça paiera tôt à cause de fautes des
uns et la tour est perdu
sinon sur sa tour à cette fin on peut
peut-être doubler avec l'auto un pote
tous promettent quatre tours emprise on
a cinq
ouais elle a l'air d'avoir bien bien
défendu un trou noir
surprise bon y'a peut-être ça aussi
ou appeler dans la f4 on reprend et
après les enfants à cinq ans voilà c'est
fait c'est le dilemme des noirs ici
d'abord lequel le cas le pont là je
pense que ça va être assez égale un mois
que quand des deux côtés façon gaffe je
pense que ça serait nyon là le client
tombe sur la hausse il va tomber ou
quoique non peut-être pas en matière
brute 5
achkar à toi car tu sais c'est nul je
pense à roissy cette date réserve
e
le temps de we found super remet à il
fatah pour cause il écoulera reiss était
donc ok donc c'est pas mal à voir donc
hoon a réussi à aborder nul donc le
score et 6 un fond noir et vu que là le
temps vient de s'écouler c'est l'heure
de passer en trois puis deux donc c'est
encore c'est maintenant l'heure de la
pause et après on repasserait en 3 + 2
donc bon les parties vont recommencer
dans environ cinq minutes le pense donc
vu que c'est la pause je vais aussi
prendre la pose je serai de retour dans
sa minute a tout de suite
ok donc je suis de retour et les parties
ont repris donc non on est patient trois
puces 2 donc oui ivan a déjà passé vous
autant l'a déjà perdue
ben ouais un peu trop temps je pense
qu'il a réfléchi parce qu'elle était un
peu surprise par cette ouverture
s'arrête dès que cette ouverture avec le
quartier c'est sans s'y attend pas trop
donc c'est pas surprenant donc voilà
donc cavalli f3c des trucs comme simples
peuvent tenter ou alors être quatre
dames de aussi peut-être mais bon là du
coup il se passe vraiment un peu trop de
temps et fait j'ai trois choix
intéressant très très bizarre d'ailleurs
j'ai 3 h 3o qu'elle avait lancé je
dirigeais théâtre
ok donc sur prix skype en aura peut-être
tour est vite je vois pas trop ce que le
fou fait ranger deux mamans je pense que
vous y fier à des idées donc bon je vais
pas trop dire grand chose à propos de ce
qu'on tue avec peut-être ça sert
elle affiche montrant c'est comme ça
c'est fou et surtout en 3 + 2 faut pas
les faire voir donc ok la préfecture
rock tour est vite c'est possible et
7000 d'impression donc c'est très facile
là ouais ça c'est possible mais du coup
il ya bien qu'elle ait prédit qu'à celui
de ses cinq peut-être ou alors voilà
comme s'il faut essayer 6 peut-être
donc là clairement elle peut il a gardé
sa tour là pour une raison nous pousser
à la fenêtre
c'est plutôt clair et pas très bas très
caché non core i donc là il prépare et 4
elle veut pas de pousser ça ou alors f5
peut-être le défend en disant qu'à
valider cette pour échanger échanger des
fous et après mais bon ça qu'on n'a pas
trop envie dans le puits dans des
changes et le fouillis en béton mais bon
je pense que là ça revienne au président
pascual or je suis pas surprise
j'ai l'impression quand on gagne un truc
à quelles épreuves de 5 à [ __ ] en jeu
set et a préféré prendre ses trois
enfants ça gagne ou alors qu'à vous
prendre des cinq royaumes or cet espace
bahia fou prend 1.16 s'attaque la dame
abbas à la baisse du courrier fana je
gagnais enfants il a juste gagné ans qu
on se fout ça donc on voit s'est passé
lors des 5e grosse gaffe très grosse
gaffe ici
elle est déjà perdante la pauvre mamadou
bah
et en plus elles sont revenus niveau
temps donc vous lifan n'a même pas en
désavantage de temps donc s'agissait
juste de juste très mauvais pour la
pauvre bull on offre donc à mettre cap
peut-être ouais ce qu'elle avait
elle a enfin essayer d'échanger ce fou
mais c'est un peu trop tard
ces cas et c'est simple ça peut se
préparer ouais moi je ferais bien
qu'elle ait cédé 5 en fait
ça c'est la police
ah bon tu te sens dans certains cas à
une fois que le cavaly bougera on pourra
peut-être poussé plus de posséder si ce
monsieur pour attaquer la toque et
répondait cesc et enfants à perdre la h
cup combattre ça c'est pourtant rien de
calais pendant dix-sept d'un fonds et hk
sagan quelques ondées 7 c'est fini ça
gagne sa gamelle elle a vu bien sûr ce
genre de coups et là nous pas un
fouillis fin d'année hélas hélas l'ohio
ouais ça c'est bien vu je veux juste
prendre à ses occupants
cet avant bon il a quand même réussi à
bord du bus le sait pas si mal vu que
normalement ce résultat il fait mal
ouais ok à 4 puisqu'on en a quatre baies
5 peut-être aussi essayé passé caricom
ont comme d'hab comme ça mais ça prend
de temps que là je pense que c'est pas
nécessaire vu que là les chauves souris
les choses s'ouvre de ce côté là donc il
vaut mieux faire des zapatistes s'est
passé le camélia ouais c'est ce qu'elle
a fait
bon salaire jour en sont tous là et là
elle à l'adar elecam active
il ya beaucoup de pièces active de ce
côté là pour les noirs face à leurs
déficits et de gérer ça
tout est dit
ok donc après comment continuer à
s'asseoir les questions à elle veut
faire kerry pc sky à corte
bien vu bienvenue et aussi elle veut
empêcher les aider la bombe en quoi
c'est vrai que dufour n'avait pas se
regarder mais les blancs avaient quand
même penser à a trouvé une petite
attaque à faire mais bon là ça a pas
l'air de trois de trot marché donc voilà
donc la salle lasserre ça a l'air d'être
plutôt bien on peut peut-être poussé g5
j'ai cinquième au classement je vois je
crois ce que ça gagne est tout
simplement donc j'ai 5 10 ans cavalier
prend faut prendre 10 ondam g4 ou
essayer de poils essayé d'attaquer
ok donc c'est ce qu'elle a fait donc sur
terrain j'ai quatre trous en défense
[Musique]
il faut trouver une dépense en pâte
septembre donc sa censure d'objets 4
patek du coup en dessous vendredi mais
sa pâleur de gagner a pleasure dome
gecas à l'art de la rue garneau faut
prolonger à cinq dames g4 faut le
trouver un truc là c'est peut-être
souffrent des trois hommes n'ont pas
vous prenez 3 du coup bas sur aff
quand je laisse un petit bal du coup
quelle province avant je pense c'est
nécessaire mais du coup il y aura d'un
projet cinq noms prend vous prend
comprend 10 3 non salerne sa dague du
bien bien sûr mais on gagne pas là à la
paperie uk elle a pris en dessin qui est
bizarre ok ok donc à bon la glace et je
suis bien je pense pas qu'ils aient
vraiment de 2 2 fut de chance à elle
elle aura aussi un portail qu'elle peut
essayer des trucs le genre genre ça a
peut-être essayé de passer la dame c'est
d'attaquer et ça met du coup le mais
qu'ils le purent un médecin va bientôt
tomber sur le cul en d3 aussi va être
avoir des problèmes
peut-être peut-être ça ici pour défendre
le cavalier baisse assez bien enseigner
aux meilleurs
ouais ça c'est bien mais mieux couverte
est d'alger dans le métro cevital m 4
le cas ici c'est qu'il ya maintenant il
n'est pas prendre un but apoula les
noirs quoi faire faut prendre htc parce
que sur calais c'est sûr d'un processus
hier flou faut baisser à foum toub et 7
et du coût d'un dame bessin qui est fou
des cinq îles et sagan madame ça marrant
ça leur fait elle peut le prendre en
face le pion à la tâche
je pense parce que aussi sur sade un
pcet d'amd sicilia le fou qui est remis
en fait c'est ça aussi qui font qu'ils
fomentent unis c'est pour ça qu'elle n'a
pas pris là bas c'est pour ça qu'elle
n'a pas pris le cavalier
ouais donc la sepronat eu place est
vraiment un des plus beaux mais l'humour
le cavaly mi temps où l'on tient donc
c'est terrible c'est arrivé saignant un
gamin déjà pour les noirs ça je pense
une a vraiment rien ni vérifiée
el aissi tours 5 elle se bat à est ce
pas parce qu'elle a envie de pousser à 3
et pour sa dernière chance pas non plus
par don peut donner là et là je sais pas
en fait pour elle se bat ici et en plus
ça ça a l'air terrible
la dame qui vient ici aussi bien aux ben
on puisse être la tour était en l'air en
plus qui est donc l afe d'amd 6 elle a
perdu la tour
donc bon jeu là même que qu'avant avec
foulards et d'amd on pouvait voir ou
alors avec des cartels maison si jouer
ça avant elle revient là donc là de son
but c'est juste drôle mal placée en lui
pour l'occasion du rap hexagonal et
répète
et apparemment les deux étaient
satisfaits dont sacrée répète donc dames
2 s'était appréciée ou alors des trucs
du genre ça
d'un des deux plus tôt pour défendre
8en ça fait vraiment maman y'a pas trop
trop de suspense dans ce match veut dire
quoi qu'il arrive on sait que vous ayez
20 nations finir par gagner la plupart
de cette partie est mon cas mais bon
elle joue bien donc c'est du goût de
sasa faut le dire ok donc ces quatre ça
serait mauvais parce que cette camry la
nissan garderai la fin ça donnerait la
carte des quatre et que nous même on
peut tenter de faire ces quatre qui
pousse alors il faut bouche les loups
pas on peut essayer de faire d'annoncé
2004 ou si après ça le plus haut rang
ces trois bruni est pas vraiment
prenables j'imagine y aura tous
retrouvés cinq fois qu'il y aura
peut-être des quatre donc que faire sur
des français c'est trop ou pas ca trù
c'est vraiment prenables pareil c'est ce
qu'elle a fait c'est bizarre en fait
c'est bizarre donc elle n'a pas voulu
défendre son camp 1-0 fait un sacrifice
aux intentions à l'eau
bon si on emmène la tour là du coup on
perd aussi le pion à 3,7 pato est la ld
réfléchit beaucoup à ma fille j'ai
beaucoup surtout en 3 + 2 au 6 euros ce
pas surtout pas là en une minute de
moins que la
ok ça c'est pas mal et va rentrer cada
mambé 5
donc la d4 sur des cartes qui aurait
sûrement tour p3 suivi de trucs du genre
ça
ok donc elle a perdu le kiosque
c'était en fait mais bon
du coup elle est quand même trouvé de
l'activité avec cbs heureusement pour
elle peut quand même faire des tours b
sat
mais bon on a quand même perdu leurs
différends portant est là elle se
retrouve avec déjà deux purs main ça
peut devenir assez moche sur un péno
bon la menace alors c'est pas la menace
est l'époux tout prend 1,7 suivi de foot
les cinq où il faut clairement pas
qu'elle laisse faire ça si elle fait un
truc du genre d'art c4 a peut-être yade
tous là ok bien hâte en attendent autant
à weedon ah bah oui parce que la
tourelle en l'air à messine ça elle a
gaffé des garçons gros carte assez fine
c'est moche ça bombarde neuf ans
maintenant elle a continué quand même
bon auquel ses bas gonnord elle se bat
c'est juste la barre pour elle ce parc
est elle se bat surtout que là il y aura
toujours des gens qui arrivent attend dé
lui toujours de cette poule à ça arrive
ça
alors éric gagné soit on laisse tomber à
l'eau il est devenu hélas déjà 2800 on l
autre chose encore
ok donc ses traits symétriques ça c'est
d'ailleurs entièrement symétrique
donc bon comprise ça ça c'est pas bien
vous mais faire un truc du genre ces
trois images on voit mettre le foulard
qui en faisant référence à des blocs
lecavalier après la dame qui peut sortir
c'est pas forcément super bien
donc c'est pour ça qu'elle ajuste
développés se montrant cavaliers donc c
est donc là la symétrie il l a été en
plus casey ok donc là ça attaque le
cavalier 400 g c'est bizarre ça déplore
que la structure mais bon je pense que
ça va gagner peut-être ça
ou alors faire daniel sera peut-être
peut-être qu'on peut même tenté de faire
de cavaillé des ans cavalier trois
femmes petites manoeuvres comme ça by m²
g37 bien lancé mais bon là je pense que
l'avantagé plutôt du côté des morts on
dira plutôt des trucs du genre ça ou
alors juste de se développer normalement
quand je regarde je suis peut-être mieux
de prendre avec l'option f
l'ordi à bien la prise avec le plus bref
en face et après vous poussez g4
empêcher ouais c'était pas mal en fait
de prendre le curé floquet elle l'a pas
fait donc hélas eschau nature avant on
peut pas trop faire gf3 parce que loin
f3 g3 sera sort en l'air
c'est qu'ils n'ont donc fait de plans
pour attaquer là ça va être très moche
bon qu'elle le temps tu m'aimais du coup
y'a juste d'un prend b2 est sûr d'un
point m6 et un lien d'un mini adam
français trolls et les nord ou en
gagnant à caen et il attaque aussi ses
deux pions qui risque de les gagnants
ok donc là peut-être il ya des trucs du
genre à damas après c'est de faire des
perpète
mais là ça à temps mais s'il retrouve sa
parfaite il faut calculer ça a peut-être
que le roi ait pu s'échapper comme ça et
à près d'un mètre 4g saint quentin
metsys dame âgée de 6 c'est peut-être
possible
ah mais non mais du coup et dévalisés de
faire la carpette wifag va l'accepter en
plus sale période et la diane ne fait
les affaires allaient déjà huit fois en
avançant que faire le carpe et ça ça
change grand chose
ouais du coup là je pense qu'elle va
élire à pascal schaer lâcher c'est trop
c'est trop dangereux pour y
donc ça va faire appel je pense à moins
qu'elles à se cacher en acheter telle
qu'elle va le faire lequel va tenter
quand même
elle à 204 m mais là mais bon je vois ya
eu c'est là c'est quand même réussi
parce que la f4 aussi qui arrivent
il est donc là le pion tombe
ah non le pire ne tombe pas parce que
surya dame moghaddam eu deux ans et
après ça et vu que la dame habitant à
100 ça a forcé changé d'âme ouais donc
le clan des tabacs prenable en effet ici
c'était pas prenable
donc c'est pour ça qu'elle a fait échec
ok donc après moi j'essaie de 5 ou un g6
d'amener sicilia et pieds sales a donc
d'abord ça et cap 6 et tout est défendu
ça sera bien douleur de choc pellicule
sur dame et huit par exemple ça c'est
l'heure de chauffer le pion d'hamdan g7
par exemple l'europe peut se cacher
facilement disons f5
ouais je sais faire dame moi je pense
dame l'ail et au poids
donc bien sûr le plus haut qu on ait pas
prenable à cause de dams à six hommes
ok bizarre ok donc elle la sphère où
donc là faut pas avoir cirier faut voir
s'il n'y a pas d échec perpétuerait je
pense que young est pas établi si
malheureusement en tout cas j'aime bien
l'esprit combatif de huy fans qui même
en mer avec ne fera avec huit points
d'avancé elle a quand même pas essayé de
faire annuler est là il chercher le gain
donc c'est bien même si là c'est
totalement nul bien sûr pas manqué moi
je l'espère très nombreux ce serait
drôle d'ailleurs sur dungey trois cas se
prénomme ok donc cellule c'est mieux et
il reste un peu moins de 20 minutes et
après ça sera l'heure du budget d'alors
donc ok c'est encore la malle cinq ans
la même avec fouet d2 et après l orage
centre d'un dédain bihan et dames g4
voyons voir ce qu'elle choisira
voilà la chose elle a changé elle a fait
un truc qui n'a pas encore essayé le
jusqu'à présent
donc c'est comme ça comme ça kajeem cinq
salles et bojan a peut-être et bougent
leurs salaires pas mal
ouais mais du coup j'ai du coup sûr
qu'aller là oui mais ça attaque l'opium
sa menace la prise à la paf et au canon
quel peut-être pousser les quatre ou à
la faire des trucs du genre ça que j'ai
quatre essais c'était semblant
donc là elle aimerait bien pousser les
trucs de leurs dessins ou mais ça donne
la cazelle 5 est aussi surpris ça le
pion est un fou et fouillent vraiment
éviter ce genre de goût
ok alors là ça a l'air pas mal qui a
peut-être détruit le genre g5l surprise
cavaliers prend après peut-être pousser
à acheter
ok donc là donc là bon ok là caché son
roi il y aura peut-être qu'avec 5 qui
arrivera
ted tour l om et tour f6 que se
passe-t-il son salaire ok donc touré
fils
c'est peut-être une menace encore mais
du coup il y aura quelles g8 nous
classer au nord de jouer un petit peu
par cavalli à 5
chaque année 5 salaire mais en son nom
donc si on reprend par exemple et a
failli gagner 4 à bas et la tête du pro
tour d'abord faire préférer riesch 4e
mais ben ouais ok mon café ça ouais ça
va aussi ça ça va aussi
ok alors ouais ça c'est bien vieux c'est
bien vu l'ordi il a il dit que f car
c'est le seul moyen de défense pour un
point noir ils sont et parce que donc
sur faut prendre si j'imagine y aura
pris il faut prendre 4 et jaka bélie m 5
enfin vente donc f4 l'idée c'est de
faire cailler 5 d'ouvrir un peu la
position aussi f4 fontfroide carte vous
prend à l a pas fait de match folle
dommage ok l'a pas fait
donc voilà je suis fils est chaud pour
les noirs gagnants à 6 là c'est
nécessaire parce que sera sa me
comprends c'est plaisant
donc bien sûr tous les coups du genre
faut prendre htc dirais que c'est paco
de f4 bon qu'elle l'a bien vu
maintenant que qu'est la bougie le fou
c'est peut-être possible en fait
maintenant faut pas à chier c'était
peut-être possible mais bon c'est à
risque et vu que sur sarah presse à
nouveau la cool and h
on a peut-être permis de faire ça là
c'est peut-être possible de prendre en
fait prendre et changer les tours et
après et après faire un truc du genre
damas trois points et c'est de contrôler
comme ça et après essayer de faire dit
des menaces a dit aussi repoussé à cinq
qui s'appelle possible auquel la presse
a donc s'en fout et f3 j'imagine c'était
pour empêcher tout rejet car peut-être
ouais bah donc elle me crie des menaces
là aussi peut être rentré en rentrer en
b 4 c'est peut-être possible aussi
ok
à 5 ça peut être intéressant oh ouais
pour un prêt à rentrer comme ça et
d'ailleurs on a toujours la prison
acheteurs hausse est toujours possible
de prendre dans la chine on pouvait le
faire avant mais le fait est que si on
faisait avant nice il y avait foule y
avait d'un cran à à 4 pendant que c'est
pourquoi collet qui l'a poussé à presles
inscrits
elle a pris comme ça projet 5 km il
assez bien
dès qu'on peut faire d'un à trois oui
c'est de rentrer comme ça et là elle a
préféré faire moi j'ai deux donc je
pense que pour elle a fait ça allait
peut-être peur de n'être 4 mais bon ça
change pas grand chose
on va aller mieux faire d'avoir trop
direct oulalala 7,7 diagonale qui sont
classés dangereux et en plus il faut
compter 5 qui arrive ça aussi qui
arrivent ou laura au nom mais ça c'est
ça c'est horrible fou soit rochus
ouais non h6 aussi qui arrivent
ah non ça c'était rupture d'arbre ans il
ya tout pour réussir cette ligne
ouais donc bien sûr elle a gagné encore
n'ont que 10 et demi à un an et demi
enfin pas mal à suivre donc
ella a fait quelques nuls qui n'était
pas vraiment nécessaire dans la
coalition gagnante manhattan juste loupé
le gain à quelques moments oui enfin
mais dans la plupart des parties qu'il a
jouées les tailles et et mignotte même
pour ça
ah ça un petit changement alors les
changements là les rafales à l effet qu
avait laissé trois cette fois il a
choisi de prendre après verdun monde a
mené trois hockey dont j'ai ma place au
fond on a déjà le sais tu pas cette
position plusieurs fois
ouais avec ça qui arrive cavale et là
aussi on va peut-être 6,6 ou alors toi
peut-être
oui donc bon là ya peut-être des trucs
du genre tu genre qu'avait eu quatre
mais même en ces termes et les epci
suivi 84
mais bon ça change ça change pas grand
chose c'est un cigare aux évolutions
d'ailleurs c'est marrant parce qu'elle a
encore joué you could have envoyé fin
elle a vraiment répéter ça c'est trop
drôle elle a répété
[Musique]
on avait déjà eu sept parties avant et
j'avais fait exactement au roi et france
c'est drôle ça ok donc là c'est un
échange de deux tours
ok donc là bon sur wii c'est bien
d'échanger toutes les pièces
mais bon je pense que même ce genre de
position ou iphone arrivera à la gagner
parce qu'elle est quand même beaucoup
plus parce qu'on sent mal personne
c'est marc henry déjà être entre
quasiment pleine finale en 22e coup
c'est drôle donc enfin comment faire des
provinces donc ok caillassage
spamicid d'affaires des problèmes tels
cas ça ça aussi ouais mais non il faut
cesser un mauvais je pense parce que tu
trouves ça sera ça donnerait un objectif
en ordre à ta question
du coup c'est quand on peut tenter ça la
finul de piocher pas s'il avantageuse
pour les noirs ou après ces quatre
essais possibles patrick est pas pour
elle a choisi de faire ça ok donc voilà
donc elle voulait pas tapé c'est
qu'après voulait pas garder à l on fait
nul
ok ok on fait nul
ok donc apparemment cui fans un peu
perdu de son fighting spirit
mais bon sa face avant du contrôle à
11,2 ça ça change pas grand chose de
faire des news ou continuer à gagner
ok donc en plus il reste un peu enfin
libéré six minutes et demie donc ça ça
devrait probablement être la dernière
porte
ok donc là elle peut faire des trucs
comme ça ça ça on s'est tous les plans
différents qu'elle peut faire ça aussi
c'est possible ça vous si c'est possible
elle sera cotée est bloqué elle bloque
tout refaire ce genre de truc qui est ce
plus normal c'est plus normal du coup et
peut-être faire sa préférée en rock west
ham 2 2 quai sur b4 camille bouge après
lequel j'ai pu me sera faible
voilà kameni dans ces trois sets est
possible
la colonne b sombre au rap abordable en
est là peut-être
il a peut-être cavalli là aussi c'est
possible tu as de faire des trucs du
genre ça aussi j'aime bien mais du coup
il y aura foule saisie directe accra
plus haut à 4
surtout celle ci avait sûrement fou mais
ça y est
monclar que c'était les chaussures
ravel et la caisse
maintenant ces quatre ça marche pas que
de sa sixième sur camille l'argent en
ayant proposé ce faire chirac
[Musique]
elle réfléchit à réfléchir
qui aurait peut-être
morlaàs petit rock et poussé f4 f5 ça a
l'air pas mal
chaleur des villages voisins pour les
noirs crime est ce possible de tenter
ces six mais bon si le fou par il ya
même pas cahiers pour real parce que le
fou le foie en mai sept soirs en l'air
ouais d'un des trois là peut-être la
tour va bouger lequel le document a4
pour pourrait être pris par le cavaly
donc faudra peut-être des formes ça ou
alors on s'en fiche si on fait autre
chose on fait on pousse f40 peut-être
est sûre qu'elle répond à quatre on s'en
fiche notamment on peut continuer à
pousser l 5 ta compo 31 pouces et quart
à troquer donc ces quatre cavalli prend
la carte que se passe-t-il en dhabi
avait peut-être ces cinq voiliers
lecavalier est informé après c'est
vraiment fait ça pour ça que laguna n'a
pas fait ça euh ouais j'ai l'impression
que de 6 à se préparer bientôt ouais ok
c'est ce qu'elle a à faire
donc bien sûr sur m6 ont fait un projet
6 ça sera quasiment finir bientôt
donc là je pense pas qu'elle va prendre
va plutôt faire une vraie âge pourrait
auquel appris à faire ok bizarre donc là
après avant elle est là seulement moyens
de se défendre avec ça donc il ya ça ça
y est après il faut trouver un moyen de
gagner c'est pas assez simple mais bon
ça là karim layre très avantageux et à
tout moment la dame peut revenir
d'ailleurs si la dame m'a l'air d'être
enfermé il va pouvoir revenir en c2 donc
là juste là et après peut-être défendre
ce fou en faisant en sorte par exemple
pour attaquer aussi elle comme au cices
c'est ce qu'elle a fait après si on veut
attaquer ça faut bouger le foudre ont
peut-être fou siens et après dans
certains cas il peut aussi revenir au
rapport mais bon s'il faut que les
cahiers où je trouve ça
donc about us hier la dompter pour
comprendre et après faire d'un proche 5
et après le cahier peut venir manger 4
dans france 5 sera un mortel soif elle
prend son temps elle réfléchit
d'ailleurs il reste plus que moins d'une
minute au timer donc aussi elle continue
pendant qu'une minute ça sera déjà
l'heure du bullet donc je pense pour pur
bonheur il vaut mieux qu'elles qu'elles
jouent vite qu'ils annoncent avoir à
commencer une nouvelle partie parce que
je pense qu'en bullet soit fouillis fans
sera encore plus forte
donc je pense que j'aimerais trop de
chance en bullet
mais bon du coup j'ai avec trente
secondes pieds là je pense qu'elles vont
clairement pouvoir enfin je pense que là
ils vont continuer ainsi longtemps
encore ça sera non quoique non à un pape
et sa semi retraite très vite en fait et
non 17 secondes mais mais je pense
qu'elle va abandonner très prochainement
surtout avec sa fille et menacé le fouet
au km oulala y poster moche ça ouah
limite obligatoire car il y arrive c'est
fini c'est fini
donc c'était là le dernière la dernière
partie de beats juste après juste après
ses prouesses donc là c'est déjà l'heure
du bullet alors vu que une mine une
seconde après que la feuille le groupe c
elle a abandonné ou non donc voilà c'est
déjà l'heure du lot
ok donc c'est très intéressant je pense
qu il va jusqu'à exploser en bullet même
on verra bien s'il retrouve d'ailleurs
je vous regarde et son ego bullet qu'est
ce qu'elle a si je peux soit comme sans
qu'elle ait son âme au but let's go son
amulette
il est pas très élevé mais hélas 2479
weave en acier ca si ça se trouve
si ça se trouve il y aura de grands
chemins en ambulance alors ok dans sa
poule de voir ça alors bon bah du coup
vu qu' une pause
je pense qu'une pause de cinq minutes
comme d'hab je vais aussi faire ma pause
et je reviens tout de suite pour
commenter le reste des partis donc je
vous garde l'échiquier du jeu coupe
juste ma caméra comme d'habitude donc à
tout de suite
ok donc je suis de retour j'espère que
j'ai pas louper une grande loge de
france je pense pas je pense que ça
vient juste de reprendre
je l'espère en tout cas ouais ça vient
juste de reprendre en effet donc voilà
donc ça c'est une ouverture une
ouverture à un peu bizarre avec b3 mais
bon encore une fois oui il faudra l'air
de mettre la pression avec avec tours h
uit aussi ça aussi c'est la femme elle
signe le hockey oui bah oui on en effet
cette salle soit bon elle avait un tout
petit avantage conservé soir était
difficile de passer avec
ok donc la sonara ti
wen bien sûr donc f5 c'est bien pour
tenir le coup en tête 5 arrive ça ouais
peut reprendre près sortir le faut
peut-être aussi faire des trucs du genre
d'am-dam ses deux pieds très poussé le 4
ok donc ça jean caillaud 5
ouais ok voilà c'est pas moi nous
intéressons faire gaffe à la diagonale
te faire flouer trois là bien sûr fouet
3 il ya paquet j'ai fait travailler
quelque j'ai quatre ans alors c'est pas
ta pour elle ça ouhlala bon donc bon
l'ordi dit que f4 ces biens n'ont donc
prise
j'avoue que je vois pas trop son idée en
pâte
j'imagine vais peut-être faire d'un bon
match 4 mois mais du coup je vois pas
son nom des aztèques ou surprise il
voulait faire un fasciste en fait ah
ouais ouais ouais ouais du coup bah
ouais et encore une fois la xfr c'était
bien la surprise faire d'un match 4 mais
bon elle est l appât l'a pas vu goulard
et il a juste ajouté ranger et ce retour
avec la paire de fou mais bon ça lui ça
lui donne pas grand chose en plus cela
il ya des six pour faire des trucs comme
ça ça a l'air juste juste je suis aussi
simple voile après on prend pas pour
revenir avec le fou créer des menaces
sur ff 7
bon ok donc la paperie fogata peut-être
en ta question fait refaire ça a
peut-être essayé d'attaquer le document
de 6
ça a l'air pas mal d'ailleurs j'ai à
dire fou fou au carrefour attaque il a
pas sans la psp go home
j'étais un peu surprise pour iphone est
venu répéter les coups tacchella je sais
ça pour gagner un peu de temps ah oui
donc là la 4g si ça va être très
dangereuse très très dangereuse en
j'imagine qu'un peu moins fait retour
des saints qui essaie de mettre la
pression commence à prendre pas aussi
bannon méprendre la ja vous prend vos
problèmes sans choquer ah ouais ok c'est
ce qu'elle a fait mais du coup c'est
plus clair c'est un peu bizarre pour
wasquehal après ça valait mieux bouger
les atouts en fait est sûre j'ai deux
après je dis donc j'ai droit à prendre
l'eau font vraiment pas parfait donc là
son final ou alliance est gagnant queen
c'est un canton bêtement gagnant avec
fight d'armes là qui arrive
moi non là ça passe et chaude
moi je dis tout simplement poussé les
plus loin elle mais quoique ya peut-être
des attaques la douce moitié
un bug b5 festirois la smat somme que le
roi doit les la tête dame de 7 ha bah
oui encore plus que la personne a
échangé les dames et il me reste plus
qu'à monter le roi fait monter le roi
comme ça
bon elle se bat elle se bat glav
si ça se trouve c'est pas si facile un
pote fallait qu'elle par le roi comme ça
après il pousse les pions et après elle
doit repasser de l'autre côté elle est
allée chercher à chercher les autres s'y
retrouve ses news fanon savait pas quand
même mais s'arrêter de rennes elle peut
même donner il faut pas sacrifier vous
qu'est ce que va faire mon maroc est ce
que la répéter les coups c'est pour ça
ouais donc elle a gagné pas très
surprenant
donc là c'est un peu différent c'est une
cécile à nos morceaux avec fougue et 5
donc à changer un peu
de faire aussi cessé de prendre de
prendre contre la caserne et 6.5 chaque
année sans vous ont-elles cavalcade
kelly smith dont on dépend aussi de
ramener l'auto à cavalli key2key de
calais b 5 hérité son expression savent
aussi c'est bien pour défendre mais du
coup ça laisse un peu le temps au noir
de mètres la tour en d4 et aussi de
doubler pour faux semblants
bon là ça a l'air de faire nul ça
petit avantage pour les blancs mais bon
vu que c'est vu que ségolène a requis à
l'eiblen je pense pas qu'elles gagnent à
hoarau lagaf et adam chesser d'un match
plein pot c'est une grosse étape samedi
9 mai l'a pas vu ou l'avre l'appareil a
fait une sacré grosse gaffe la cabine ou
blanc l'a peut-être qu'elle va réussir à
gagner sa première partie où le nord
mali n'ont donc la quelle des six qui
arrive damage 5 aussi attaqué peuvent
faire ça enfin dans le match 5 dans le
match 5 bon il risque d'aborder le père
fait ça le souci
voilà c'est ce qu'on vit à perpète voilà
ça c'est trop moche ça
ouais parce que dans l'avion et or après
la une arrive alors ira voilà donc ces
perpète demain des forums mineur parce
que la taille proche
et donc la tâche qu'elle peut faire des
trucs du genre adams et de après m'être
les tours là ok web mais quatre gay
c'est bien vu la dame l'a peut-être
peut-être ok mais 5 ha et j'aime bien
simple en fait selon bienvenu de sa part
sur monsieur qui allait prendre sur quel
point il y avait eu 3 c'est pour ça
voilà donc là c'est la rengaine on est
noir c'est peut-être de pousser ses 6
ces salaires nécessaires aux in usa du
coup ça ouvre la colonne f
et on peut mettre la pression sur
l'option voilà ça c'est une intéressant
à diouf parce que prendre avec la tour
c'est super mais à cause de ça il ya
près à la fin on gagne et donc ouais
c'est intéressant
du coup ils échangent les pièces et pas
prendre date je pense d'abord prendre
ici et après pendant l'e3 s'être fait
refouler des cinq aussi mais bon vous
rires prendre les trois points
donc là je pense aux tests il ya ptet
que mon awa pour france d'ici on aime
deux tours en panne ont donc
sa salle des cibles fodé sakho 6
possibles way
ah oui mais au milieu aussi bien les
gaffes ou des 4èmes faut bouger la trop
il faut bouger la tour parce que surtout
repenser cette yahia faute et ça ça a
l'air bien a dit hart ça ok pas parce
qu'on faisait 4 s en fichait meilhat
cahier en fait ok oulalalala ouhlala oui
fin d'année en soi
au moins cela gaffe pense à ces superbes
auch
ok donc mais voyez donc oui il va
peut-être perdre sa première partie
bon peut-être à venir avec le roi
chercher les pions ça serait des pc puis
sur s2 mende a perdu enfin enfin après
un très bon en grosse partie à l'an
dernier
quoique peut-être fait ses armes aussi à
trouve elle a réussi à sauver sa attend
elle aurait dû faire à temps et essayer
vous fo des buts annette sauvé son camp
elle avait deux pions elle aurait pu
revenir avec le roi se trouver sow veut
ça mais bon la garde des sceaux ouvrir
du toit elle sauve rien du tout ici
wacker voit que tout peut arriver encore
à tisser retrouver le sol un moment
savoir elles seules elles seules sont
attendus kumo
ok ouais donc aller bébé qu ericsson 3
avancé la la ça doit passer
c'est fini bon bah enfin il a perdu sa
part est parti
quand ils en classe et ses filles si
elles se trouvaient avant encore vu
qu'elle est allée hier oui les femmes
s'y retrouver m'adresse à partir en
craquant
ok
donc là centre de pions assez bien pour
les blancs peut-être qu'on peut sortir
le fouet sortir la tour
quel est sont consultables dossier pour
intégrer le foie
le forum a ajouté mme spieser choix
bizarre on a pas ce qu'elle va prendre
ça moi c'est ok donc là si la dame bouge
j'imagine me prendre ici ça prend plus
la dame peut-être venir en v3 pour ta
question
c'est possible ou la face des trucs du
genre ça enfin je veux dire après après
dame en 2003 et voilà c'est plus
possible
elle n'empêchait
donc là c'est l'art bien pour les normes
ce et va réussir à prendre nos pions
bientôt
ouais le clan qui tombe donc ça a l'air
d'être d'être bien mais peut-être je
vois oui en plus il ya tellement d'armes
de 6e à la carpe au lac aof
l'option x berrada mena c'est fou ça à
la gare au messianisme c'était juste en
mars les prophètes si elle se trouve
elle voulait juste prendre l'option et
la gav est hélas hélas juste eu un
problème de souris faut deux parties de
suite qu'elle a perdu willy van sant
julià temps d'abord imaginons qu elle
avait peut-être un peu pitié debout là
c'est pour ça qu'elle a évolué devant
les défunts
bon malheureusement plus l'hommage se
finit bientôt parce que si ça se trouve
c'est comme une architecture qui prendre
l avance si elle continue comme ça
ouais ok j'ai bien dit parce que bon
c'est pour ça qu'elle a fait est simple
parce que ce moment ça c'est pas
possible
ok ça en fait ce retard mouvement donc à
quatre peut-être à l'échangé défaut
parce que si on bouge d'armé aura tours
qui peut être embêtant pour des listes
soient tous rythme en simple aux
trembles attentes même en du coup elle
l'a fait ce qu'il y ait trois peut-être
est rappelant que bouger la dame en d2
pour attaquer le curage this way
salaires n'allait pour en faire un pays
voisin
on a dû échanger les voeux pas ivoiriens
souffrent de deux pièces dont la main
d'oeuvre
du coup au canada à abala on peut
prendre le q1 j'ai l'impression que le
client était prenable
il est toujours d'ailleurs d'abord
prendre à 8 à fait probant de d1
une petite gaffe de la part de guy noves
bon ils feront fait henri iii et son
cavalier c'est vrai voilà c'est vrai
c'est vrai et plus créer des petites
menaces
ça a l'air d'être par email à camille
défend bien sur le plan n'est pas
prenable parce qu'il ya la fourchette
donc voilà c'est pour ça qu'elle n'a pas
pris c'est pas si clair parce que sur ça
il ya cavani 6,6 à banon c'est clair en
fait à paris c'est sacrément coeur est
passé fille bella belle précision de la
part de folie va donc elle a réussi à y
gagner malgré ces deux parties elle est
revenue un peu
et ça risque d'être la dernière partie
de vous parce qu'il reste plus qu'une
minute et 23 secondes
donc ouais ça risque d'être la partie
décisive dans tous les cas on sait que
wifag va gagner mais mon dieu ça pas
très sadique mais s'ajuste la finit la
partie finale
vous êtes rue les gens qui essaient ça
me file pour ensuite ouvrir à colin h
essaie de passer comme ça si elle prend
aussi soin on reprend et après on a
toujours un champ et on peut faire des
sacrifices peut-être pas pas sur sa
objet de défendre avec x 5
voilà c'est très bloquée cette position
très très mauvais
déjà des dames s'il vous prend à chier
si je tenterais bien mais la femme c'est
que racaille et j'essaierai confins de
variantes mais bon on peut dire que ça
se tente mais c'est sûr qu'elle est sain
qu'il y aura sûrement g7
c'est pas gagné
le temps vient de s'écouler ça va c'est
la partie finale alors officiellement
qu'elle détient carrière pour un quart
ici pour faire quelques messages est
donc finie cheval revient un peu dans la
partie
il a réussi à trouver les faiblesses
ça défend bien
[Musique]
alors que faire si aulas donc ça ouvre
le clash mais est ce que ça sera
possible de l'occuper ça sert à ça la
question parce que je pense qu'il est
très difficile de vote il y aura
toujours tour des tours d2 qui arrivera
dans le pire des cas
donc ouais tour d2 autour des 3
peut-être je suivis de dépôt comme ça
peut-être d'un mythe à la main bon je
pense que fouillis fans à café comment
les lagafe olalalala s promat bientôt
ouais donc les bulles est sacrément
passos on ressent pour un fort alors un
appeau folie différemment ouais du coup
elle a perdu quand même trois parties
sur sur combien de l'autre on a fait sur
5 je pense donc sa perte depuis sa patte
à baisser d'année à partir du coup et là
elle a fini sur une défaite
c'est vraiment dommage pour elle mais
belle remontée de kunar alors donc
celles avancées telles avoir du match
c'est à la fin du match et ça parce que
le times vient de vient de s'écouler
donc voilà alors c'était aussi la fin la
fin de la première phase de jeu de la
première voilà donc juste mettre les
appareils mort en fait
le bracket
voilà donc c'était sympa ça donc là on
peut voir les impatients des rondes
précédentes donc là il y avait là une
eau qui a gagné nan albanese et qui a
gagné dronneau vanille bibi ça va late
in grille est stéphanois est aussi sympa
ici mais aussi un homme aux yeux quand
on gagne on est donc là on peut aussi
rajouter fouillis fans a laissé des
joueuses qui ont gagné et donc comme
vous pouvez le voir là elles vont se
rencontrer
donc là katerina langnau va lever contre
la night danza n'y faisait par exemple
et fouillis fans à la prochaine ronde
jouera aussi contre trois militaires
donc voilà et c'est un système de chaos
donc quand on gagne on avance à la ronde
précédente si on perd on se fait
éliminer
donc c'est un système assez cool et donc
la sallaz c'était la dernière partie ces
dernières parties et et voilà donc c'est
fini
si je veux juste être les apparitions
voilà donc là comme vous pouvez le voir
qu'on a déjà fait toutes ces parties là
et là la dernière qui reste c'est un
parti pris fin angot nord donc ça
reprendra je pense dans quelques jours
on comprendra donc dans quelques jours
ça sera ça serait là le début de la
phase 2 qui seront les gagnants contre
les gagnants sont donc voilà ah bah
merci à tous d'avoir regardé j'espère
que vous avez apprécié les commentaires
et bravo à pouilly fans du coup parce
qu'elle a vraiment gagné là vraiment
bien joué malgré ces pauvres fins et ses
défaites à la fin elle a perdu trois
fois quand même à la fin en bullet donc
c'est assez moche surtout vu son
résultat avant mais bon c'est le lien du
coup pour boule noire qui a bien réussi
à surmonter
bon au moins elle partira avec karim en
tant qu en peu de victoires donc surtout
qu'elle a réussi à gagner la dernière
c'est plutôt bien pour elle donc ok bah
là moi je vous dis à bientôt je serai de
retour sur an pour pour commenter la
phase 2 donc
et si c'est pas moi ça sera une autre
commentatrice donc dans tous les cas
vous aurez les commentaires pour la
phase de mon coeur à bientôt